[Music]
in YouTube pressure news oh I feel it
hmm you to pressure submitted by tall
[ __ ] club but is that cool like
[ __ ] and use in a good way yeah yes
it's a power we took ownership of that
word it just took ownership of [ __ ]
that's right yeah
YouTube's top creators are burning out
and breaking down what's new I feel like
every other week someone's like doing a
I gotta be honest news but what are they
like it's like dominoes yeah every other
day someone's like the couples that I
got I'm changing it for him I just feel
burnt out and they're like yeah the
couples break up
they're like a serious video who did it
so i know Casey nice that did one yeah
Casey nice that did a burnout video or
did a breakup video a burnout would but
he did it in his own way damn like
burnout or like I'm taking a break I L
girls girls yeah she she did when L
Mills L Rubio no he's good number three
he's the third most popular you know
that's wild he's just under 30 mil
youtubing is rough though so for a lot
of guys that don't know like unlike TV
or their seasons there's no periods of
hard work and then like oppressive break
it's just people get mad at you when you
take a break like if you take a week off
for vacation like David so and just
disappear and then come back whatever I
bet the steve bourie move to prep your
fans you just disappeared
yeah I did like a drunk absent father
and then you appeared out of nowhere but
the second in said hey
find out the second time I bounced I
gave people a heads up and the reasons
why so cuz the first time I kind of
realized it was a little [ __ ] up but
that's also more responsible I've never
seen another youtuber besides Steve that
has a million subscribers on his YouTube
and only 40,000 Instagram apology that's
putting together media kit for our movie
uh-huh and I was like getting stats and
stuff and I was like yeah he'd never
posts I'm always like pause that game
but he should do it more like you should
do it more often
yeah so here's the little youtubers I
mean we're not videos that we just
mentioned well I've seen them before 30
minutes oh that's 30 million is gaming
right I think you go is it just cuz
there's too much pressure to come up
with new content and people get greedy
they're like like your old videos were
so much better and then people and then
content creators gets so much [ __ ] but
like a lot of it so I'll go through the
yeah she blew up and then she like she's
like I already achieved all my dreams
and like this short span and now I'm
depressed and I don't know what's what
if she do Nicki she I don't really watch
her pond I just saw her burn a video cuz
it appeared in my future well I know
what she does you can see her at my
house this Friday if you like yeah but
in the burnout video it she like all
these different people being like Elle
Mills elementals Ella Mills and she's
like I just got big so fast and then
that's legit though there's a lot of
people that get depressed from achieving
everything too fast because I guess in
her yearbook she was like most likely to
be a YouTube star right and like she's
only 19 so that was only a year ago and
she's like I worked my ass off during
that year and then I did blow up and now
I'm like I don't know what to do what
now yeah that's a really comedy maad but
then now that she's achieved her goals
like now she's even more sad and she's
like this doesn't make sense like I'm
living my dream it makes perfect sense
there's like fighters that become
champions and all they wanted was that
belt and once they get it it's like now
what or a lot of child actors that win
Oscars yeah they're like you hit the
highest achievement in acting I'm really
happy that I've never made it the goal
is to appreciate the journey not really
the destination that's important your
office I mean if you overwork you're
gonna burn out no matter how [ __ ]
happy that [ __ ] makes ya like like sex
is wonderful right but if you [ __ ] every
[ __ ] day I mean I aggressively too
much and you come like so much now
becomes like torture I don't think
people like it's so funny I just had a
conversation with the friend yesterday
and then she was asking about kinda
she's like you've been in a rut right
and like she was asking like well you
took time for herself and I was like
well you know there's a huge difference
I was like a majority of people today
like even in the YouTube space I seldom
really believe in anybody's [ __ ]
when they say I do a lot of this stuff
for myself and know hardly anybody does
that anymore
no you know and so because she was
asking me so well why'd you stop doing
oh how come you only post when you want
or it's like because I don't do this to
post for anybody else I do for myself
yeah so what whether you like my post or
not doesn't stop me from posting what I
want you know so she goes what did you
get on your last videos I don't [ __ ]
know I haven't checked the views of my
videos since ever
no it's hard it's not negative 10,000
some people make making their living
from the videos because don't let go
exactly because it's this thing that you
used to do for fun but now you're making
your living for it from it you quit your
job and so if you don't do the types of
videos that get views and you do the
stuff that you love a lot of times that
doesn't get feels like for me the
channel started out a sketch comedy and
I love writing and I loves acting and I
love sketch comedy but those weren't
getting views anymore and so when
everything I was doing a mix of sketch
and vlogs but then the vlogs kind of
took over because you know like that's
what people were watching and it's like
I keep putting like a lot of my heart
and soul and money and
and time into the sketches and and then
it like nobody's gets to see it and
what's the point of making it if nobody
goes why we stopped doing JK films I go
back and forth all the time cuz I'm I
it's hard cuz it takes like yeah five
days to finish and complete the sketch
and that's been running fast and a
production team and my team you need to
buy props costumes you need a call sheet
yeah hey you guys are stressful human
beings and I just do it well that's what
I'm saying like people always well why
don't you add editors why don't you do
this because that's my channel like I
never did you to to make [ __ ] money
right buddy was a bonus you know so for
me it'll always be a bonus so it was
always a bonus in the beginning and then
when you start making that shift you
know when you're like okay this is now
my job because I want to put my whole
focus into it and then the algorithm
just [ __ ] you [ __ ] you in the ass yep
nobody loves the algorithm not once
every day yeah exactly right now or they
could switch it I could switch it
because it used to be short content wins
and then it used to be briefly that
rotella creator they never timing
content to do deep I came up that was
when every [ __ ] front page thing was
minecraft gaming was up and I you see
any gaming stuff and here's the other
thing to people the audience gets super
pissed about clickbait and so do
youtubers youtubers don't even like to
do quick bait but the algorithm makes it
right now so if people don't click on
your video in the first hour they don't
even give it to all your subscribers
even if they have notifications turn to
handle yeah it doesn't even matter they
won't even show your own subscribers but
the problem that you're all talking
about right now all has to do with money
it does it but it doesn't have anything
to do with content creating see and
that's my dad no but no it doesn't know
because the reason why you would you
just said right now is because the
algorithm bit and I made a living off of
this so if you never made a living off
of this like it wouldn't be an issue
yeah well that's what I'm saying yeah
yeah yeah even if I made a living I made
a living off of YouTube and I still do
to this day but I've never cared about
that check only like a small part of the
and that's when I was the most miserable
because I was like oh what am I wouldn't
why have my numbers so low because of
this day and when I let that go and I
just started to create there's other
opportunities out there which is wide
life there's brand deals there's
something else as well you know and I
think like these kids are experiencing
this because we didn't have to go
through this in the beginning I didn't
have to yeah what am i YouTube was for
me to become the best data community on
earth that wasn't the original but see
that's that's a thing the og youtubers
none of us were making money in the
beginning everyone was doing it for free
everyone was just doing it for fun we
had to get invited to the partner
program yeah you had to apply you had to
have people refer you you had to show
that you were part of the community it
was a big thing
so it's RIT like you really appreciated
that honor and now kids you know just
blow up overnight they think it's always
gonna be like that and then they get
burnt out because like their number
started dropping or things start
affecting things and they already bought
a car and bought a house and all this
stuff yeah exactly
and it's just like this society of like
value it's like where you place your
value what you place people's value of
themselves is always based on what
somebody else tells them now it's like
I'm a valuable person because I have X
amount of likes I have this amount of
Instagram followers and then people
glorify you for having that type of yeah
and it's never so much about what you do
is about what you present now so that's
like the biggest issue that I have like
if I think about having a kid now like I
almost don't want them to be a part of
that world because later on they can't
when they're an adult yeah but at first
no just because like it doesn't teach
them to value themselves as people learn
about yourself or you know some people
after all what's important what happens
at YouTube explodes tomorrow then it
[ __ ] explodes who the [ __ ] cares I
got my family I got my friends I have my
girlfriend I have my religion I'm good I
had those four things I'm good that's
why we diversify so yeah a lot of my
friends who have played the game and
blown up their channels and like gotten
big they're like you got to play the
game you gotta play the game because
then you can make the type of content
you want because you want you know
you'll have an audience there so it's
it's really hard man to make that
decision because you're you either do
like stay what's you know authentic to
you and like you just just want to write
in the so you're like I'm just gonna
write but then you've might miss out on
a whole group of people that might love
your writing if they only knew about you
so the exposure part is hard I mean it's
just you got to stick to one [ __ ]
thing and do it well that's about it you
know what I mean because if I thought
about just trying to reach everybody at
once I wouldn't I would definitely not
curse as much as I [ __ ] do right now
you know I mean I wouldn't talk about
controversial things I wouldn't have an
opinion about anything I will walk
around and I do stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] and
make people laugh all the time which is
fine you know what I mean like these
kids they [ __ ] work hard yeah and
they dedicate their [ __ ] lives to it
but the only problem with that is like
this burnout [ __ ] it's because you've
based your existence on what everybody
else called validation yeah it's
validation that's why you see people
like you know we even have some but like
like people like Youssef you know I mean
like Youssef had his meltdowns a couple
of times and we've seen him where he's
open about his but we've seen him when
he was just getting thrown from the
Drake you know and then he came down to
this office and he was like you guys
really think I could be anything from
YouTube and you're like yeah dude just
keep going it was a quiet timid kid yeah
yeah and then he blew the [ __ ] up and he
the person just completely changed now
he's the outspoken guy that's opinions
about all these things but we've seen
him change in gross sorry yeah and it's
then this is the same story with
everyone here it's like people grow
people get an audience they have a voice
they have people that listen to them and
then all of a sudden it's like holy [ __ ]
I'm burnt out I can't do this no more do
you think the platform like YouTube
should have some sort of like mental
health type of like help for their
creators it's not their responsibility
like it's like Veterans Affairs where
you like it's you're getting PTSD from
war I think like going into whatever
you're doing you should be prepared for
it's like I think it's up to you to know
yourself and take breaks and you can't
really put that responsibility on the
endeavor your responsibility is just
like it'd be nice if they also cared
about that's also asked you a Mount
Everest to have a hospital at the top
you know it's like if you're gonna climb
Mount Everest you probably should bring
an old first-aid kit yeah and it's like
if you were to open a restaurant like
restaurant owners get burnout - it's the
same thing like if you were to open to
business any type of entrepreneurial
thing
where you're creating your own hours and
you're building something for yourself
it's hard and it takes way longer than
an 8-hour workday it's like you're
working 14 to 16 hours a day building
this you're gonna get burnt out and
that's just that's just the path you
choose you could you could quit any time
that any of them could quit any time and
get a nine-to-five job and then not have
to think about it or they can work on
themselves and go to therapy there's
options I mean I don't think it should
be like up to the president of
restaurants to like make a mental health
facility for them there's mental health
facilities available i I encourage
everyone that is burning out to speak
more about it and experience because
what happens is like on social you know
influencers what they do is they make
their lives look great and amazing be
like you know pursue your dreams do this
guys whatever right that's the same same
spiel that everyone has what they don't
tell you is the sacrifice like hey I had
to miss my mom's birthday party hey I
haven't hung out with my best friend in
the last three months I have to miss my
brother's wedding sounds like you're
complaining probably like that's the
reason a lot of people don't talk about
it but but the thing is it's like
there's a lot of sacrifice and suffering
that goes along with success that goes
along with this stuff that now you know
entrepreneurs are coming out and talking
about the realities of like hey I only
slept two hours for the last seven days
their relationships get put on hold yeah
hey I had three divorces because I
didn't spend enough time with my wife
but I'm a [ __ ] billion but yeah it's
balance there's a lot of realities like
that that people put themselves into but
it's like if you want this title if you
want to become this youtuber I think
yeah that just has to be it's like it we
have to explore that and talk about it
more and I do that a lot because I want
people to know the reality of it you
know people do do that because it's the
hot thing to do right now what oh they
have a conversation so they've turned it
and they made into a [ __ ] joke it's a
trend it's a trend now so like that's
they can't it's cyclical they cannot get
out of trying to please people like you
mean it's like an angle like they're not
being authentic about it
boils down to its being authentic yeah
their emotions may be real but it goes
down to like the motive to why you did
it is because oh [ __ ] other people are
doing it now too so and it's not because
you're trying to inform people is
because you're trying to get views so
you still haven't broken out of that
cycle you're still doing the same thing
so you're not getting better from it
you're still trying to play this game
some people I think burnout is actually
good too I think without burnout yours
no change
you're never challenged to reinvent
yourself so like look at a lot of our
favorite artists like let's say Kanye
write his first three albums similar
sound maybe a little bit of like
evolution Danny starts coming out with
some crazy [ __ ] even more crazy [ __ ] and
then I think for a lot of people that
his original fans are like what the [ __ ]
it'll sounds way different but maybe he
experienced burnout to the point where
he really has to challenge himself
creatively and I think if you're in the
creative field you're gonna be stuck at
the same artists
if you don't burn out I think burning
out is a necessity to grow as an artist
ground and that's just part of the
creative field like if you're
comfortable with making the same content
like 20 years straight
you're a factory you're not an artist
you know you're not man you're China
you're a manufacturing company but you
have to if you're if you want to be a
creative person in this creative youtube
field you must face burnout and then you
have to brainstorm and how am I gonna
reinvent myself and go around it and
come back as an artist and I think
that's what makes a great artist is
someone that can constantly face burnout
and reinvent themselves face / not
reinvent themselves I think a lot of
like youtubers who have stayed on this
space for the longest time have done
that because there's a people who who
have done the same thing over and over
like Nicki like sketches to blogs to
cooking shows like that's it's all
survival you have to yeah yeah and they
don't they don't exist now and they
wonder why they're like I used to be
their psyche was because you did the
same thing over and you you just live on
the past I used to be I used to be I
think the thing is is if you can keep
your voice consistent you know like
doesn't matter when you go from sketch
to vlogs to whatever you have the same
perspective and you have like the same
voice if you can keep that person but
that met consistent then it doesn't
matter what format you do you can you
can reinvent yourself hundreds of
different ways and your audience will
grow with you and burnout is great for
the ego because people that don't face
burnout and depression
he's feeling this hi and they always are
on top of the world and they don't know
how to come back to being a human mm-hmm
so once you face that depression and
burnout it's actually something that's
like a wake-up call like hey you are not
invincible wake the [ __ ] up
restart again
[Music]